[Music]
disney's live-action version of mulan
is not a shot-for-shot remake of the
animated classic from 1998
instead it's more of a reimagining based
on the ancient chinese poem
the ballad of mulan and while so many
things are different the heart of the
story is still there
along with plenty of nods to the
animated original here are all the ways
disney's live-action mulan
is different from the original oh and
warning spoilers ahead
when the new movie starts mulan is a
child and we watch her grow older on
screen
but in the original we see her at only
one age for the duration of the film
mulan's surname is tweaked from faw
the cantonese pronunciation of her name
to hua which makes it truer to the name
of the original ballad
however both names have the same basic
meaning later when mulan needs to come
up with a fake name for the army
she settles on hua joon as opposed to
pha ping from the original movie
it's ping ping there are also some
changes to mulan's family in the
live-action version she now has a
younger sister
in the animated version she's an only
child though she does have a dog named
little brother
while in some versions of the original
legend she's an only child
there are other versions where she has
siblings also missing from the
live-action version
mulan's quirky grandmother thanks to the
film's longer running time they were
able to more fully flesh out the bond
between mulan and her father
in the new version mulan carries her
father's sword with the words
royal brave true etched into the blade
the phrase is repeated throughout the
film
speaking to the theme of the story loyal
brave
true but take a look at the sword in the
animated version
you'll notice both sides of it are
completely blank another iconic object
from the original movie
remains unchanged boulon's hair clip
with a flower on it
in both movies she leaves it behind to
signify that she's left home
in the animated movie she leaves it by
her parents bed in the live-action one
she leaves it in her father's wardrobe
but there were some elements from the
animated movie
that just would not have worked as well
in live action specifically
mulan's anthropomorphic animal sidekicks
like ricky the lucky cricket
qrikey was a crucial part of the
matchmaking scene and the troublemaking
bug causes chaos after soaking in a cup
of tea
in the reimagining instead of a cricket
a spider pops up on the table mulan
tries to cover it with a teapot
ultimately ending in disaster pricky may
not be in the movie
but he is there in spirit one of mulan's
fellow human soldiers is named cricket
and like kricky he's called a good luck
charm
yep this cricket's a lucky one another
fan favorite and a controversial
character missing from the film
mushu the dragon who was voiced by eddie
murphy you might recall that the
wisecracking creature
served as mulan's guardian sent by her
ancestors while mushu was popular with
u.s audiences
chinese viewers found him to be
trivializing so no mushu means no scene
where he shatters the dragon guardian
statue that is actually supposed to
accompany mulan
instead it's mulan who accidentally
shatters a statue
that of a phoenix the phoenix makes
sense as a mushu stand-in and not just
because the two creatures have a similar
look
after she leaves for war mulan's father
prays to the ancestors and the phoenix
to protect her so while there are no
actual ghosts of ancestors seen here
we still know they have mulan's back and
the phoenix follows her silently
throughout her journey
other characters from the animated
version are present here but with new
names
instead of shan yu the leader of the
invading northern army
is bori khan and he has more motivations
now than just wanting to conquer china
khan also wants to avenge his father's
death bori khan is fighting with the
rurons
not the huns as shanyu was in the
original
this might be more accurate some
historians have said the huns were
likely more focused on attacking europe
than china during mulan's time
alongside bori khan is a completely new
villain to the universe
named xinyon in the animated movie
shanyu does have a falcon
which also acts as his spy but the
falcon never takes the form of a person
according to the filmmakers they wanted
to bring in a new female antagonist as a
way to balance out the protagonist see
both characters are able to harness the
power of qi
concept that is never mentioned in the
original it's apparent that mulan can do
this early in the film
and later on it allows her to do
everything from jump across rooftops to
scale walls
another one of the animated characters
wasn't necessarily removed but rather
divided up
according to the producer jason reed lee
shang the captain who notably got down
to business
was split into two separate characters
one is commander tong
mulan's mentor and the other is a fellow
soldier named huang hui who grows close
to mulan reed also said it didn't feel
appropriate having an older commanding
officer be her love interest
in an interview with insider animated
mulan co-director tony bancroft
said that they actually considered
making li shang mulan's equal
originally they had another character as
the sergeant who would have turned out
to be a spy once that character was cut
li shang got a promotion one of the most
iconic parts of the animated mulan
is missing from this live-action version
the songs instead of making the film a
musical
memorable lines from the songs are woven
into the dialogue
for example mulan says yes it's best i
will bring honor to us all calling back
to the song
honor to us all and while you won't get
to hear donnie osmond saying
i'll make a man out of you the sergeant
does tell the young warriors we're gonna
make men out of every single one of you
at one point mulan sits at a table with
some fellow soldiers who talk about
their favorite characteristics in a
woman
ling holds up a drawing of a woman he'd
been matched with that looks similar to
those sketches from the animated scene
poe then says i don't care what she
looks like i care what she cooks like
which is very similar to a lion sung by
chen po
in a girl worth fighting for and while
mulan never sings the words herself
the tune for reflection can be heard on
the score during several brilliant
moments throughout the film
while the basics of the story are the
same some major plot points have also
been altered
in the animated movie the toughest
obstacle the commander throws of the
soldiers is making them retrieve an
arrow from the top of a high pole
while holding a pair of weights in the
live-action movie they also must carry
full buckets of water to the top of the
high mountain
in the animated training montage they do
train with buckets but it's large sacks
they're carrying up a mountain
in both movies mulan is injured but in
different ways
in the new movie she's hit by one of
shinyan's throwing stars but in the
animated movie
she's slashed by sean u's blade which
ultimately leads to her being stripped
in a medical tent
and revealed as a woman one of the most
dramatic moments in mulan's story is
when her secret is revealed
the live-action version has her being
the one to make the decision to out
herself as a woman
in the middle of battle she lets down
her hair and shows her true self
it's an especially empowering moment
that gives the character more agency
this scene also might explain why the
live-action version doesn't show mulan
chopping her long hair off earlier with
her father's blade
this battle is brought to an abrupt end
by a huge avalanche a famous scene from
the animated movie that director nikki
cairo decided to keep in the live-action
film
but instead of shooting a cannon in the
new movie mulan tricks boricon's men
into firing a large boulder at the
mountain
and nobody is seen rising from the snow
on skates this time around there's no
victory parade in the city and while
shaun you met an unfortunate
firework-related demise in the animated
movie
boricon tumbles to the ground before
mulan finishes him off with one of his
own arrows
and if you were waiting for fireworks
that doesn't happen until mulan saves
the emperor who
played by actor jet li has a much more
active role in this film
venturing out to fight his enemy when
mulan returns home in the live-action
version
her father says it is my daughter that
means everything to me
in the animated version after handing
him gifts from the emperor he says
something different but with the same
general intent
the greatest gift and honor is having
you for a daughter when mulan gets a
visit from commander tong it's not a
romantic gesture
rather he comes with a new sword as
mulan's was destroyed during the final
battle and a second invitation from the
emperor to become an
officer in the emperor's guard in the
ballad the animated movie
and the live-action movie the emperor
asked mulan to come work for him
mulan always declines choosing instead
to return
home the film ends before she can give
an answer but it would make sense if she
wanted to fight again
because in the ballad mulan and her
comrades traveled together for 12 years
were there any other big differences you
spotted between the animated and the
live-action films
let us know in the comments